I think a lot of people have trouble
with end games and for several reasons I
think one of them is a lot of people
don't like don't study and games and
mainly because they don't like studying
and games and another reason is because
endgame is the last part of the game
by the time we get to end games you're
pretty tired so it's kind of hard to
play them and that's why my coach always
recommends to me that if I'm going to
have a three for our study session -
even if I'm going to the end game during
this session is to do them towards the
end of the study session when I'm more
tired and it's more representative of
how game goes not when your mind is very
fresh and you see everything clearly
so the I have a couple of my games that
I wanted to go over and they're all both
rook and games and the thing about rook
and games unlike fun and games they're
not hmm
they can it's very hard to calculate
them all because in pawn and gains a
number of moves is limited because pawns
such limited piece it can it can only
move so many squares so you can just
calculate them out but routine games are
a little trickier there is more nuances
to it there is more subtlety and I think
another misconception that people have
about end games they think like they
don't treat them like the rest in other
parts of the games they don't they don't
think like you know now it's the time I
have to calculate something out very
precisely like if I make a small
miscalculation now honestly unless you
see your opponent is doing something
immediately a lot of people think oh you
know I can just make a kind of quiet
move or not defend now so you know I
think the same principles that apply to
the rest of the game can be applied to
the endgame for example when you see
your opponent doesn't have a thread you
should ask yourself okay so what's my
weakest piece and then you try to
improve something so I think a lot of
times people just don't really know how
to handle end games and then they think
they miss some subtleties they don't
really they don't really sometimes they
don't calculate it very precisely
because especially with work and games
because we're okay
against it can be very tricky and sneaky
and ok so I want to start with a puzzle
because I like to start all my lessons
with a puzzle so white to move
okay so if you're telling me move you
have to give me a variation
okay so instead of winter it wrong what
all right so 1835 is no straightforward
move so it has to be calculated today
I'm not going to talk a lot about
theoretical positions I'm just going to
talk about more practical aspect of the
endgame but if something comes up I'll
go over it so it takes so everything is
forced so this position is a theoretical
drum if the point is all the way on a2
and that reason is because to win queen
versus King Queen versus pawn endgame
you need your King problem is here you
cannot bring your King because it's
still meat and then if you move your
queen then I'm going to move my king
Anand rating to get a queen so in other
positions when you're doing this okay
let me do this let's say this kind of a
position and I have a queen so the way
we win this position is I force you with
checks to go hide behind your pawn which
means you're not threatening to get a
queen and I bring my king in in this
position in it in this position you
cannot do that because when you force me
behind my pawn I'm in stall me so this
is a draw against rook pawns so Quinn
against rook pawns on Bishop pawns when
the pawn gets all the way to the second
rank order sound rank is a drop so let's
try something else
I'm not going to go on the P file I'll
go to King a one and then we got the
same position
well
the difference before you were in the
corner
yeah well let's count okay so I'm going
to push here here here here here
wait whose turn is it same thing right
because you also wasted a temple you
played okay - yes because a lot of time
in rock endgames you you have to know
some concepts and some theoretical
positions but you also have to do
precise calculations it's a lot of times
it's a combination of both so first of
all what happens if I just move my rook
the pawn will take is this a win or a
draw
why it's because my King so far if my
King was closer these two past ones
wouldn't matter
rook is better than two first and so
forth so what to do right the difference
between root K 3 and like root K 2 or
rugby 1 is now is the King has to move
with two moves
so if you play here
okay does anyone know how to win this
position oops
we have to bring it but to bring our
Quinn closer so one way to do it is we
can either do a check so we can simply
play this move and now there is no e2
because there is meat so the king can it
has to come out so we check if the king
goes to a-1 which of course the most
logical movements to push a2 then we do
this and we have to attack the pawn and
check the king at the same time and now
we just make a move when this one is
ours so if the pot hasn't reached all
the way to the second rank then it's
going to be a win with a queen so what
if after rook a3 what if I play before
the your pot my phone is three moves
away from winning so if I move my king
and queen my pond and so this is the
time you have to calculate very
precisely just like any kind of position
where you need to calculate okay so you
want to move your queen okay so okay so
the first one is obvious we have to move
the rook somewhere in the third rank so
what's your plan you won't play route d5
so move the king so let's count you
don't even have to calculate simply
count so your king is gonna so I'm 1 1 2
3 moves away so in 1 2 3 moves you're
gonna get here but also remember you
have to waste a move to stop me from
winning so your Kings gonna so if if you
bring your king I'm going to play here
you bring your king again I'm going to
play here and now you're the one who has
to make a drug
much closer now you're the one who's
making it wrong
but there is something significant so
there is another pun another two points
on the board so what can we do
right so we have to go after this a pond
so the good thing about having a lot of
extra pieces sometimes it can give a lot
of it back so for example not there it's
a rock t5 so if I go B 2 now you can
play here and if I try to Quinn my pond
you don't even care because your own
point is going to Quinn
so you don't care about your roof
anymore you don't need it what if in
this position I play here so now you're
falling for some trick and now again
your kink so far away rock versus pawn
because you don't have your king it's
going to be a draw and you didn't catch
me yeah good yeah rook e8 because we
have a skewer so here I can either check
on yeah you can either do this or I can
push my pawn because if your Queen I
have asked you but you don't have to be
fancy you can just check but you have
the difference between rookie to in this
position so any route moves you're
wasting one move but the difference is
when you play rook a3 the king has two
ways to moves as you play King gate Oh
King game on so you actually gain a move
you know question what's your question
but then I'm going to go in with a check
oops and I Quinn with a check and again
your pawn is on it's not on the second
ring so I'm going to win same thing I'm
going to move my Quinn closer actually
here you have a simpler way you can just
check that the King moves away you put
your queen in front of the pawn if the
King goes here play him and you win the
pot okay so that was the puzzle so my
next game is actually one of my games
from the US Championship that I played
in in April it's against one of my very
good friends international master is a
goalie tianyu it's one of the most
entertaining and games I play definitely
and it was a very up-and-down game so
I'll show you how I got to that end game
so we start it off I'll just run through
the meal games I should do this so we
got to this position where black is
getting completely dominated on the
Kings side all my pieces are there this
Bishop is horrible
my bishop is going to come in even
though we have opposite color bishops
and just a quick note opposite color
bishops are great when you're attacking
because when you attack let's say I'm
attacking the dark square so it doesn't
have a bishop to protect them so it's
even worse for her and here I actually
had a lot of time and I keep calculating
calculating I couldn't come up with it a
win and let me see if I might win here
yeah and my win is actually pretty
simple
what am i doing
yeah she played rook c8 so here I can
just play here just bring my bishop in
non threatening checkmate and I don't
care about trading because if King h6
undo this knight of seven and checkmate
so I calculated calculated I couldn't
find this and I found something that I
thought was going to be something very
brilliant but unfortunately I missed
something so here I played Knight f3 d4
so she went back so I took so I
sacrificed piece and then Bishop h4 so
this was the whole idea of my sacrifice
because I thought Bishop h4 I'm just
going to win the game because of my
pawns on g6 and h6 o her queen is in
such a horrible position and then I just
missed this 95 move and actually I was
kind of lucky because this endgame
because of my pawns it's still good for
me so I played Bishop f6 and now I'm
down a whole rook but I have these three
pounds so how to evaluate or even how to
approach this position so for her it's
hard to do because it's moved 48 so it's
time trouble so she has to make a quick
decision but now we have time so how to
approach a position like this
so what's going on in the position I
know it looks crazy but we have to break
it down somehow
right so whenever a lot of changes
happen in the position it's always good
to stop and reevaluate the position
because we went from a position where I
was close to check meeting I like I
could feel it like I knew there has to
be something and I keep calculating and
I can find it it's very frustrating you
know I can count yeah I go and I can
obviously I miss calculating and I keep
sitting there and my clock is ticking
because we're close to move 40 and I'm
calculating items I'm not finding
anything and I just know it has to be
like how can there not be anything in a
position like this and then I end up in
this kind of position so of course like
I was really shocked that this is where
I ended up because I thought I'm
completely winning and then I kind of
started looking at this position I was
like okay it's still not so easy so I
have what do I have I have two points
for a rope but I have three pawns on the
sixth rank so what else so yeah so
blacks rooks are very badly placed
because if someone is coming so it seems
like I'm going to get the rook back so
I'm not going to be without rook forever
so let's see if she tries to save her
rook to f7 so let's say she runs away so
actually here I have a very interesting
way to win the game another thing that I
need to keep in mind whenever you're in
any kind of an game you have to keep in
mind what's going to happen in the
kingdom pawn and game because for
example if I play g7 and I can force the
rook back right so she has to give up
the rook
but do I want to go into rockin pound
King opponent game no because she has
this distant past pawn so this is
something decided things that we have to
keep in mind so first of all what
happens if she tries to save a rook
so how to approach a position like this
or how to approach the same way we would
approach the same any position ancient
so what are some of the questions were
asked right so her weakness is her King
which means that's why I have to play so
somehow I have to go after her King
because that's the main problem in her
position my strength is made three ponds
and the fact that her King is bad on the
downside I'm down a rock and her pond is
going to Queen so if I don't do
something immediately I can just lose
very easily so how to take advantage of
this King yeah if I do this this
I mean it's okay it's going to be the
same thing but okay yeah so first of all
one thing to calculate we first we
calculate the force lines because there
are straight forwards would get them out
of the way and then we can want to
something else so here here so
unfortunately now I lost both of my
pawns and now I'm going to lose this
pond too
Oh
we're all
so like in this position like group to
five I can so now she's going to start
pushing her phone
Oh
okay but our opponents King is weak so
if we're going to attack it's going to
move with our pants on the rook so where
do we want our work to be Hey - very
good do this so what's the idea after a
four actually there is a there's a
fourth win in this position already
that's a very cool way of course I
didn't see this during the game
okay rookie selling what was your answer
what was your answer see I don't want to
give up my pawn first so because when
you give up your pawn you're really
giving your opponents more options it
would happen okay so here and then
rookie seven but now most you're
threatening is either perpetual or
winning my rook so now I'm going to run
away again
so again f8 is a very committal move if
you're doing f8 you need to have a good
follow-up but you can play rook e7 with
the same idea of playing afraid so let's
say your opponent ignores it
there's already a first win and
so I say enforcement and I can calculate
force variation okay someone
oh okay tonight and then rotates night
and then
and that would play Knight to g6 and
then
I said again so choose seven okay so
that's check okay so let me see if I
take on each six you're going to get a
queen if I go back you're going to
checkmate me
nothing I can do okay so if I take my
night yeah you're right yeah what I mean
you can also see you're being fancy can
just get a queen no but yeah yeah this
is yeah because it's a discovery check
wait limbs so if I go here then you're
gonna get a queen and then you get my
rook
so if I go here you checkmate yeah I
mean I of course this is nicer it's
always nicer when you end up Ramone yeah
so you can do this you can also play a
feat with the same idea so g7 so what's
the move here it's not taking the route
right so because they want to put my
king under the discovery tag and now you
can get a queen I mean night so you have
to get a queen so actually obviously I
cannot do this so it becomes clear that
black has to give up one of the ropes so
the question is how so you're going to
lose your work to one of like one of my
pants is going to take one of their
books so how do you want to do it
right
that's one way of doing things that's
right so why do you want to take the
DuPont I mean you can't just let me play
f7 and then let me take one of the one
of the routes so why do you want to take
my Jeep on I'm so it does one right
because you don't want me to end up with
connecting two connected pass phones
because those are the best kind of fast
ones to have so you want to get rid of
this Jeep on because then I have two
weaknesses so there are two ways you can
do it so in the game she took on g6 and
I understand why it's not a bad move ish
there's another way of doing it but I
understand why she did it because in a
48 most years to make a decision and
route g6 and we get into some kind of
our route gain game where I'm up a pawn
but my pawns my parts actually no longer
I did great so she can choose two ways
of playing so she can either play rookie
f8 so if I go f7 nope
now she's to give up the pawn the rook
and get another pawn so now the problem
for me is this h6 pawn becomes kind of
useless because it's block the king is
going to come and get it so now I have
to go after her pawns so it shows a lot
of weakness system so here and what to
do now
so again we have to be accurate
so you've got so again you're going to
lose a pond and this happens a lot in
games like you're going to lose
something or you're going to go into bad
position and you have a choice like how
do you want to do it so here you have a
choice like which one do you only lose
how you want to lose that pond so you
have to keep these things in mind so
obviously something is going to get lost
here so for example so first of all you
don't want to do this so this is called
passive defense when you're behind your
pond or behind protecting and not doing
anything so we always want to aim for
active defense sometimes that means
giving up a pond but we get activity so
a lot of times does your rook activities
words upon so you don't want to just put
your rook here because now I'm going to
bring my king now I'm going to cut this
off I protected my pawn and now my king
is going to come and support this one so
now all of a sudden this pawn became
dangerous again so you don't want to
become so passive and let your opponent
do so many things so you want to really
come after my pawns but think about how
you want to do it which pawns you want
to get and what's going to happen so
rook c3 is one option with other options
as black hit it's a very simple thing
your pawns under attack so
rook c5 again passive defense before
your pants on return just move it the
difference is so let's say you take so
whichever your route goes if your route
goes here I'm going to take this kind
nope I'm going to take this guy and
defend it if your route goes to b5 I'm
going to take this and defend it so
eventually then I'm going to take the
other phone and we're going to end up
two versus one end game so what do we
know about end games like that or when
you have a pass fund and your opponent
has a pass fun so there are several
important things right your King
activity your rook activity how far
advanced is your past pot so this h6
phone is very far advanced but the
problem is it stopped so when I play
King gauge 7 you either have to put your
hook somewhere awkward to defend it or
you have to give up that pawn and you
have to pay attention to my pawn so my
pawn is pretty far advanced this one
this before pawn and your king is not
close to it so let's say you wanna so
you cannot bring your King because I'll
take this with a check let's say I make
some kind of a move cutting off my king
and then you go for this and now we're
just going to exchange everything
eventually and all of a sudden this King
becomes very awkward okay so how did we
get here so I think this is an actual
sadhus during the game and I thought
this was our best way to play and she
took on g6 which of course logical move
gets rid of that pawn disconnects my
pawns so now what changed in the
position
so we didn't get that f6 pawn
so what's bad in whites position now the
rukon district is horrible
Brooke on g6 is misplaced it's not doing
anything doesn't want to be there it's a
horrible horrible kids so how to take
advantage of that rook
King eat seven actually is not a very
good move who can figure out why rook G
it for the same reason is not a good
move so let's cover h7 you need seven
so King ate seven so how can I fix my
rook think temple moves so-so f7 so rook
has to go to f8 and now rook f6 it's
actually very funny structure because my
rook alone is holding all your pieces
together so black is to continue with a
four so this is similar to the game so
we'll get to this position so just leave
it here so root G 8 is the same reason
I'm going to play of 7 so you don't want
me to put my pawn on f7 and the rook
behind and actually this is an ideal
setup right um I'm putting my rook
behind the past one which is what we
want to achieve so how else to take a
battery rookie faith right just don't
let the rook move and unfortunately I
don't have anything better but to play
f7 and then transfer we saw this
position right
remember this position no no one
remembers me just listen
so before so we got to the same position
so again your opponent's going to take
your pawns you're going to take these
things are going to get traded off and
also remember that in n team's passed
pawns are kind of like a destruction
when your opponent's trying to do
something you're pushing your pawn all
of a sudden they have to turn their
attention to the pond and then you get
freedom to do what you want so it's not
just about winning your pawn because a
lot of times you don't get to clean your
pawn but use it as a distraction okay so
in the game so she can play rock your
faith but again it's important to ask
yourself these questions and you're
treating this just like any position so
I mean it's a complicated position a lot
of people think end games are simple and
you know there are a few pieces but even
with few pieces you can have
complication like okay move
like how complicated is this position so
again you have to ask yourself the same
question so what is my opponent trying
to do what are the weaknesses what are
the strengths in the position what is
one string that like is in this position
look right here's two versus one and
it's a distant past pawn so if this pawn
starts going then I have to move my rook
to the other side of the board and again
it's going to be distraction for me and
that's something that's going to happen
to my pieces on the Kings side so here
she actually played a four and actually
this cost for the game
so what to do
so okay so take sake let's make the
first obviously I have to take I'm not
going to play before and lose another
move so this position so again things
change the nice time again to reevaluate
the position that's pretty good summer
right so what my trick is still very
much misplaced so white has very far
advanced past but unfortunately they're
both stopped so how so how to deal with
this a pawn
okay I definitely want to have my route
behind the pond right like I don't want
to do something like play here and then
come to a2 and take this pond I don't
want to let something like that happen
because again I'm going to lose this
pond
like I don't want to love this so I
definitely want to put my route behind
the pond
but again you're going to lose your pawn
so if you play room q7 same thing you're
going to lose the spots g5 okay that's
interesting
all right so I'll rocks your file let's
calculate this move
so if I push my pawn you want to get
this pawn
now okay there is some fortune left
seven okay so let's calculate this move
actually I haven't looked at this right
so if I go rook f8
yeah I mean this is this is also a good
idea
so if route k5 here the important book
that you have to make you don't take
this pawn you have to protect your own
pawn because this pawn is yours
it's not going anywhere and the key is
you also want to get this deep on so if
something like this
ah no because their blog got a passport
to a black has not passed pawn because
in that position I was able to play
rooks III and get one of the B or D
punch right oh oh you mean that position
you mean in this position yeah yeah oh I
see so you want to play up seven so if I
go here you go here over here oh yeah
wait so here ah there's a slight
difference because now I can play here
and get your pawn because in that
position you're I was taking your pawn
on a3 and here I'm taking it on a tune
but here we don't have to force things
so here we're playing an endgame so
what's our worst piece now our rook and
what's a piece we want to use King so
it's a tree really that big of a threat
uh hello let me see
there we go
is a tree going to win the game
right so why is it a three big threat
here right because F 7 so f 7 is a
temple move so it's like in one move I
can get behind the pond so f salmon rook
F 8 and I can swing my rook over but
that's why it's not such a big threat
because I have time to swing my rook
over and it's going to be behind the
pawn so remember if you have a passed
pawn yourself you want your work to be
behind it if your opponent has a pass
that's fun again you want to be a route
behind it that's when it's most active
so that's why this a pawn is not that
dangerous so here it's not such a danger
because I have time to bring my own king
so here is what's important in this
position like which one I want to kill
which ones do I want to give up
so which one does it look like I'm going
to lose
how-how's plugin I get to F for fun
which one now out of 4 points even f6
and 86 considered f1 right it sounds
like I can I can't hang on to that phone
because I need to push this pawn to
swing my rook over to the other side so
that f1 is going to be gone so like we
know that much so this h1 is very weak
maybe I can hang on to it but it seems
like the h1 it's not that important
because it's a rook pawn and it's very
hard to win with rook pawns especially
well I mean if there are other pieces
and it's a draw so I know I'm going to
lose this pawn so now what what do I
want to do with my King and okay I know
I'm going to lose this fun I know I can
easily stop the other pawn I don't have
to worry about it
so not have to worry about my if my idea
if my opponent can activate our King
so is King h7 over threat
because what was my response to looking
its own now root yourself f7 and then
root cap 6 and then you cannot move your
pieces right so now I can just move my
king so where am I going with this king
somewhere at g5 or g6 somewhere to
protect my pot and attack this point if
I can win if I can trade my F&H pawn for
this two pawns then I'm going to win
because I have to pass pawns
so these two passed pawns this DNF pass
ones are better than then fh+ pawns
because this one's our stock so King h3
actually during the game a lot so turn
the game at that King g3 might lose to
this move but it turns out that wait did
I do something wrong yeah there was a
reason why this move was imposing what I
forgot but that's not important so yeah
King HD I talking issue was such a
clever move because obviously when you
know pushing your kings like you want to
go towards the center and then I start
work g8 and then I couldn't figure out
what's going on settler Kincaid's same
idea and no problems so she played King
gage 7 so what happens let's say if she
goes here so you want to play f7 so I
know it's hard to analyze and actually
it's funny because there are so few
pieces on the board and it's so
difficult to analyze because there's
just so many things going on and this is
what I mean when people have this
preconceived motion notions about end
games they think they're simple or they
don't really think they'd have to put in
all the work they usually doing the
middle game but yeah you're right
there's a lot to analyze you so now we
can go move by move so you basically
have to think about to move 0 f7 get the
power right away our King gauge for so
if you can move by move then your
calculation will be simpler so let's say
King h4 then what can black do
okay so a 3-under
so 18 all of a sudden becomes dangerous
right now he wants to I mean black wants
to quit so now we have to go after the
pan so f7
so now what's going on in this position
again that's a good time to do a summary
material or even
right so yeah I mean that's a very good
summary so why it has a better King so
first we'll start with materials so
materials even why it has a better King
White has better rook the past fun is
mine I can take it whenever I want to
and that's an important thing to keep in
mind so for example if my opponent makes
some kind of a move let's say she plays
King gates Emma so should I take the
pawn or should I do something else right
what my king g5 because here I'm not in
a rush to take the pawn and that's a
very important thing to keep in mind
because this pawn is not going anywhere
it's my pawn I can take it whenever I
want to I don't need to rush and another
good thing what's good about taking the
pawn on the third-ranked specific not in
general specific in this position why is
it good that I'm taking the pawn on the
third-ranked I'm protecting my own pond
so if you do something let's say here I
can play here and then you come after my
god
yeah so the his pawns are going to be
mine okay so let me ask you something
okay so for example if you place here so
now we're going to use our king so now
again I'm not going to take this pawn so
I'm going to play here and if you can't
protect it now I'm going to make a
meeting thread and now this is even
worse for you because now you're okay to
go all the way back now I'm definitely
going to take all your pawns so and this
is because I was able to activate my
King and in that critical position black
wasn't able to really find you know
what's important in the position and how
to continue precisely hey for I think is
a very understandable move because you
know you want to create counter play but
unfortunately I didn't work out so okay
so King h7 so what was the response to
King H on f7 so a3 do I have to worry
about that one no not yet engage for now
I have to go yeah so she took my h6 pawn
but let's say she takes here
yeah King g5 and again I'm going to
start taking the spawns and then hope so
again some kind of a move always keep
the subtleties in mind so if you can
throw in a check and worse than your
opponent's king it's always worthwhile
to do it it didn't cost you anything but
you always worse in your opponent's
position so they sorted these are the
small things that always come up in
rougane games let's say you can't take a
pawn like in this position okay let's
say I pass the move to my opponent I
just want to set up a different kind of
let's say this is the position so I can
take the pawn but I can first throw in
this check worse in her position and
then take the pawn it doesn't cost me
anything it makes her position words and
this is something that comes up in
rougane games a lot you can throw in a
check do some kind of a damage and then
do what you want it to do so instead she
decided to take this h6 point because
you probably thought that other because
in this position this position looks
quite hopeless because these pawns are
going to be lost
okay so she played a one Queen and then
she's like so hard to win this
so the first thing we do actually again
now again to do a summary what's
important in this position and do I want
to hang on to my pawn or do I want to
activate my king
I mean she's not going to do that right
she's not going to let my King in so do
I care about this f7 pawn
I mean I can't hold on to it because you
can never take it but the problem is how
am I going to make progress
so this F seven point is that's
important to me what is important to me
activate my King activate my rook and
make her position work so what's the
move
so Rocky six push our King back do five
so she took
rook f6 unfortunately move okay yeah
that's all I did I played rook g6 and
route g6 the I thought this was very
clever because there's no King f8 force
an exchange of rooks
and and this is what I made you have to
keep in mind hard upon and games for you
so she played King gauge 7 rook t6 so
since I'm attacking this f5 pawn with my
king and she has to keep her rook here
to defend it I'm going after the D pawn
because this Pony I know it's going to
be mine I can take this D pawn and then
come after it there's no way she can
bring her King around to defend it so
like I've reserved at pawn so now I can
go for the other pawn so here 24 and the
reason I'm pushing it after I play let
me see this so I see like if I'm that's
not my move ok so I'm up I'm careless
here all of a sudden we might end up in
feel it all kind of positioned so you
know even in this kind of end games even
when you're completely winning you want
to be accurate like rook end games
really require this kind of thing so d4
and the good thing for me is that my
opponent really doesn't have any moves
so she's completely paralyzed you cannot
improve her rule cannot improve her King
which gives me the option to improve my
position as much as I can and then take
this f5 point because again we have to
worry about think about what's important
in the position this f5 phone is going
to be mine at some point so I don't have
to take it right away I can think about
what's the optimal time for me to take
it which of course is not it's not in
this position either because again I'm
losing this one so I'm going to have two
extra pawns
so there's no
so when I get to defile because here I
got my pawn all the way to d6 so I can't
play Rookie of six right away but again
she doesn't have any moves so here we
don't want to blunder and then and
actually it's not a wonder and why did I
take it I guess I wasn't even being
extra careful but I was a blunder for a
second but no but I mean okay it's good
to be careful rookie six returns rookie
seven now I remember
and then yeah I was actually thinking if
I should do this
unfortunately this is a draw oh no need
to be so it's good to be careful no need
to be fancy yeah so here and now my rook
is going to block all the checks so my
pawn is cleaning I have another game but
that's a long game so we're not going to
be able to go over it so I hope you
enjoyed it I enjoyed playing this game